foreign
but mostly let's make it just me and
welcome to the 282nd episode
[Music]
we started out my dogs are barking and
you know how that goes man those in
cells can sure yet uh and uh you know
they're gonna be yapping you might hear
them in the background and it's all good
we are doing this podcast we usually we
do podcasts um in the evening we do them
at like 5 p.m that's a little BTS little
behind the scenes little uh you know
podcast magic you know what it is we're
doing we're we're showing you the sauce
right now we're saying uh yeah okay
sometimes we we shoot them and record
them at 5 pm and now you know that
that's when your boy is off the hinges
right but right now I will say this is
Halloween technically Halloween and uh
right now today I know you're not
listening to it on the Halloween because
we have to do the editing and all that
[ __ ] a little bit behind the scenes a
little bit of sauce exposing exposing
the sauce but um right now it's noon
dude dude wow [ __ ] it up so hard it's
noon dude it is noon right now so this
is the midday podcast we're coming to
you live from the midday podcast fast
and it is the midday it is the noon it
is the technically afternoon
podcast but you might be listening to it
not at noon but we're coming to you live
from noon not necessarily live because
we're editing it together but we don't
normally cut things out except for the
patreon episode if you want to sign up
for patreon it's
patreon.com crystalia but if not you get
it cut up a little bit but we're still
rugged and raw
oh
anyway we're coming to you live here
it's crystalia.com we're doing a lot of
dates here uh we just came from uh the
road we just got into the road we just
came from the road and we are going back
on the road we are performing in Denver
have you been there we are we'll be in
Denver by we I mean me we are uh Dan
Edinburgh let me pull up these tickets
here we're going to Denver Denver doc
Denver grizzly.com uh we got Denver
tomorrow we got uh Cheyenne Wyoming on
Sunday I say tomorrow I don't know what
you're when you're listening to this boy
he's he's assuming and that's not good
but it's um Denver is November 5th I
don't know if it's today you're
listening to the podcast or whatever uh
Cheyenne Wyoming on November 6th uh I
got a bunch of uh Club dates here too
just to just to keep fresh here Boston
first show sold out the Wang theater
3500 tickets second show on sale now and
it's uh it's getting close there so uh
November 12th I'll be at the Boston
Boston Massachusetts Wang Theater Albany
sold out
um and I just picked up
Brea California
for New Year's Eve come on and celebrate
your New Year's Eve uh [ __ ] with with
your boy christilia.com Brea California
we'll be there I think we got four shows
there
um and then I'll be in San Diego on
January 7th and Portland Oregon January
20th and Seattle Washington January 21st
that's almost gone uh
um Sugarland Texas that's near Houston
so go get your tickets there anyway New
York February 18th and Chicago February
25th uh you guys and we got mid lane and
up just go to chrisley.com we got a
bunch of things we're announcing Austin
soon
we're announcing Ohio date soon
we had to look at chrisley.com you get
the good tickets I posted on Instagram
follow me on Instagram chrisley.com uh
Chrisley Instagram
um but yeah dude we're chilling my
babies and uh it's good we can go to
chrisley.com get your merch
um we got the you know it's it's fall
now we got the brown life rips uh
hoodies and we got the other hoodies the
cult hoodies they're real nice dude your
boy wears them but let me just tell you
this man we're talking about being on
the road
um
let me just say
Tempe I was in Tempe okay I did four
shows
sold them out and and I just did
uh Phoenix a few months ago and sold
that out Tempe
straight up I love you
Phoenix I love you Scottsdale you're all
basically the same play I don't know I
know that like there's like you're all
like the cities are too popping they're
too on and popping to be so close to
each other they're like 15 minutes away
and they're so on and popping and it's
like just make one big conglomeration
the conglomeration I call death row
ah dude
the conglomeration I called the
conglomeration I called Tempe Phoenix
the conglomer region I call I call
Scottsdale
that's why I [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ] the conglomeration I call
Arizona but um
so uh yeah man it's it's so and you know
what it doesn't matter where you are
when you're there if you're in
Scottsdale Tempe or Phoenix I will tell
you right now it doesn't matter where
you are because no matter where you are
if you're there it is the number one
capital in the world
where dudes wear backwards hats in the
pool
[Music]
dude
Murray yes are you a dude
yes are you in Phoenix Scottsdale or
Tempe yes is are you gonna kick a dip in
the pool yes this is how people take
dips in the pool when they're in when
they're [ __ ] 18 to 45 in Scottsdale
Arizona at the W Hotel this is how they
get ready to go to the pool get the hats
that's what they do they go like that
They Go shirts off get the hats
um so it's unbelievable dude if you wear
a backwards hat in a pole in the pool
you are a you are Mighty that's all I
gotta say you are just so mighty but
Tempe Arizona came out we love Tempe
Arizona God that Club is awesome shout
out to the Tempe Arizona and uh and uh
and all the people that work over there
uh love you the staff was awesome
um and the fans were awesome and we had
a good time dude Brent Morin came with
me and uh did the shows it was like a um
what do you call it it was like a
reunion man it used to open for me 10
years ago and uh
and the dude's great man it was really
cool it was super fun we went there and
here's what I did I went to Adam Ray's
wedding now you might know Adam Ray
because first of all he's in a lot of
things as an actor second of all he's
got a fan base as a comedian and third
of all he was also in the tour report uh
Vlog that I did for I don't remember
where he came oh uh Peoria and Rockford
and uh Adam Ray is one of my best
friends he's a great guy he got married
in um Phoenix Saturday last Saturday
um
congratulations to him and Amanda lovely
couple awesome awesome time but what I
did was because I'm smart dude what I
did because I'm smart was
okay now is Adam a comedian yes does he
have a lot of comedians that are going
to be at the at the at the at the
wedding probably okay because he's a
comedian and we're we're involved in
that world so what did I do as soon as I
got to the the the take the ticket what
do you call the invitation did I book a
room no I booked shows the two days
before it because I wanted to be the
comedian that got the dates yes is he
selfish or is he just forward thinking
is he self-centered or is he just
thinking about you know the plan here
and then what he did to do he waited too
long to get the hotel room and it was
booked and he had to stay somewhere else
dude
somebody first for my babies but also
brought the fam brought uh Calvin
brought Kristen Kristen uh aunt lives
there
Aunt Lynn and Uncle Carl and Uncle Carl
laughs like this
um and it's absolutely unbelievable it
was a beautiful time of friends and
family it was a beautiful time at the
Tempe Improv it was a beautiful time and
you know I tell you this man
uh Brent was there David Sullivan came
there too you know him from the tour
report in Savannah and also just from
you know having Andrew Jackson here and
being in uh you know
being in small town Wisconsin
uh I always joke around about him like I
can't believe [ __ ] 900 people saw a
small town Wisconsin but it's actually a
[ __ ] great movie and it's uh and it's
a killer it's a killer thing there it's
a good movie and it's doing well and
it's making the rounds on the freaking
um what do you call it the uh
the the what do you call them the
[ __ ] Festival circuits we forget the
words Festival we forget the word
Festival dude and I'll tell you why I
don't know why but I need to take ginkgo
biloba but I will tell you I don't take
the [ __ ] Gabapentin anymore
uh because of the word recall and I
still can't remember words like festival
and it's [ __ ] amazing
but uh
uh
uh so we went to Tempe
checked in a hotel stayed in a hotel was
a great time and then we went to and we
did we did the shows and then we did we
went to Adam Ray's wedding me and
Kristen and uh all the other you know
people there that were there it was just
a beautiful time man let me just tell
you about
how great
and you know I don't know if this is
because I took
look I don't take Vyvanse that's not my
thing I don't take Vyvanse but I happen
to take advantage today and I'm really
got married because I wanted to make
sure to be there and be present and you
know when your boy takes Vyvanse it's
like he might as well be the captain of
a [ __ ] boat I mean he's just in
charge and he's telling people what to
do in a nice way though right not in a
like hey you do this way and I like hey
why don't we do this and it won't make
the time that much better and then
people go like that's okay you know and
there's some outliers that are like I
don't know but you know as time evolves
and we keep going then we realize that
well the captain was right and it's
mostly because of the vivance now
um I was at the wedding and it was a
great time just beautiful time first
Jewish uh wedding I went to sorry Kanye
but uh I did go and it was beautiful and
they crushed the glass and uh Adam Hit
It First Time immediately and when I
went to Eric Griffin's glass uh wedding
he didn't get he he [ __ ] it up he
didn't get the glass crushing the first
time and I think it's I think it's like
a hidden thing that Jews kind of
secretly know how to do it because
Adam's Jewish and Eric is not Jewish so
uh and by the way Adam had a completely
Jewish wedding like with a rabbi and he
was funny all rabbis are funny as [ __ ]
you know because they secretly want to
be stand-up comedians and um he was
talking in Hebrew like a lot of the time
and for for [ __ ] [ __ ] if I know if he
was just bullshitting you know what I
mean Hebrew is one of those languages
that I think I could probably speak if I
just felt it
you know what I mean like Japanese I
know I can't do it I have to learn
Spanish it's too close to English I
can't learn but Hebrew they're just like
sometimes
I feel like if I just hooked into Hebrew
I could just [ __ ] absolutely just
fired it out there you know just get one
of those scar those tablecloths put them
over here and then just put a mini hat
on and just
died and
um
so you can hook into Hebrew but um
yeah so Adam hit that glass and it just
crushed it it was beautiful and Amanda
looked beautiful and Adam looked great
Adam never looked better Adam had his
hair nice dude we didn't know what kind
of hair Adam was gonna do he did the
nice hair dude and uh you look great man
I'm just so proud of these mother Colvin
really [ __ ] weeded out who was Bout
It Bout It and who wasn't bout about it
right like covet really we like when you
were in covid
you lived with somebody you really found
out if they were bowed about it
right
you were with somebody you were with
them all of a sudden every day and you
found out if they were Bout It Bout It
if they weren't about it or by the way
maybe you're not proud about it and it's
okay but you split up but congrats to
all the people that made it through
covet and found out that your loved one
or your spouse or your girlfriend or
boyfriend or partner whatever it is was
Bout It Bout It dude
and let me tell you something man I'm
glad that they're bad about it because
that wedding was a great time and I
don't know if it's speaking but so I was
at the Jewish wedding and there was like
a you know a nine-year-old that
challenged me to a dance-off and I
realized after he challenged me to a
dance off I I left and you know I
I think I kind of won the dance off he
did one move over and over again and had
the L on his forehead saying I was a
loser but I I feel like I kind of won it
because I was doing a little bit more my
moves were more you know they were
versatile my moves were more I was
picking from my bag of moves and he kind
of just had like this one Fortnight
dance that he did
fine whatever he thinks he won and but
then I realized that he was dance
battling everybody and I was like the
fifth guy that he dance battled and he
was calling me John Wick because you
know I look [ __ ] crazy good in this
suit uh and I got the black tie and I
don't even know why any year old knows
who the [ __ ] John Wick is anyway because
that movie is so violent right like
maybe call me Men In Black Hey kid
you're eight
right
it's like he's just like you know hey
look at the character from Sling Blade
he's like well that's entirely too grown
up for you to watch that movie
hey you look like the woman you you look
like the the [ __ ] the the husband and
woman under the influence are you
talking about a John because of Eddie's
movie from the 1970s
and doing a fortnight dance
so um anyway I [ __ ] I I honestly ice
that kid with my moods but I'd let him
have it because he's a kid he didn't get
tired at all dude he was doing like all
sorts of [ __ ]
like I mean his wind is great when
you're eight your wind is crazy good
dude
um so like between counting all of the
[ __ ] together I won the dance you know
my wind isn't as good as an
eight-year-old's Windows wind was
awesome and he only did one move and I
was picking from the bag of tricks right
so
uh anyway that's the other here no there
um
forgot about the [ __ ] Hava Nagila
forgot about the Hava Nagila dude dude
how funny is it when David Alan Greer in
uh
it just does it in In Living Color and
he's like
have a tortilla dude I left so hard
forget it I left so hard the black
Jewish dudes doing the holiday
one of the funniest men alive but um
yeah so I was so all of a sudden they go
like this hey time to lift up the couple
in chairs and I go like I'm like Homer
in the [ __ ] dipping back into the
just hey time to lift up the the Jewish
couple in the church me
right I'm a homer getting back into the
plants like into the brush because dude
uh uh hey dude I'm not I'm not dropping
anybody and guess how I'm not dropping
anybody by not picking them up I pick
him up huge percentage even if there's a
little chance I might drop them
that's a bigger chance than if I'm not
picking up anybody
so they go Delia get over here you know
why they did it right you know why they
did it let's not [ __ ]
you know why they did it
I'm broad I got a tall drink of water
I'm real broad I could I could lift I
could lift [ __ ] up right
but what did I do though
they go there's Adam and there's Amanda
but what did I do though but I go well
let me just I'll go to Amanda because
she's mini right Adam is a man and I go
let's have a chance to drop in the the
you know the the the petite lady then
there is dropping you know Adam and he
had like I mean Adam's uh [ __ ] man
right he played Wolverine in uh in
Universal Studios when he was younger
and uh so I'm doing it with like there's
like you know a bunch of people with uh
do you know doing the chair and we lift
up a man and I realized I'm the one
that's holding the back of the uh chair
only me okay I'm holding one of the
bottoms of the chairs and then the the
and I look and nobody's got their hand
on the back of the chair so I'm crucial
to this mission
right we got [ __ ] like straight up
Jaleel White and Joey McIntyre and me
and I'm not that's no joke they were
really them holding the chairs and then
me like this with the back and I'm the
only one and like
I know Joe McIntyre is good with the
group because he's from New Kids on the
Block but he's not doing teamwork right
but I'm like and I think you're far from
your [ __ ] New Kids on the Block days
dude come on
and I'm sitting there holding the back
of the chair and I'm like if I if my
shoulder gives out
we are done wedding
over Dude
but guess what though dude
I connect with my breathing right
and I go hey I don't think I'm not gonna
drop her
I know I'm not going to drop her
we eventually put her down and you know
it was we were doing it for a while and
I go guys yeah we should probably and
then we get down and then we put her
down and then I go [ __ ] yeah dude and I
walk away do it again
Homer in the [ __ ] back of the bushes
right
[ __ ] I didn't know that you
gotta lift more people up
like we did the couple and then all of a
sudden tap tap I look over Joy McIntyre
and I go oh god dude
[Music]
oh God
the wrong stuff I'm not doing this dude
and Joey goes bro you're you're a big
guy we gotta we got it there's more
and I go
oh okay
dude
guess who I gotta pick up
the [ __ ] father of the bro
dude he looks like he played for the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] husky what's that corn husk
what's the [ __ ] did the guy look like
he played for the [ __ ] Nebraska what
is it
Corner Corn Huskers
he looked like he's a [ __ ] tight end
for the [ __ ] Court I mean the guy's a
man dude he's just a and I'm like Jesus
and in my head he's taller than me I
don't think he is because I'm a tall
drink of water but I'm like we gotta
pick him up okay and then as I'm walking
up to the thing with Joe McIntyre right
I'm like
okay Chris
remember the shoulder thing how sore it
was holding the back and she's petite
so this time do it with your left hand
okay so I'm thinking about this as I'm
going up to the [ __ ] thing and I'm
like you know I'm secretly I'm like all
right look I am a big guy Joe McIntyre
said it okay I'm I'm done to play it's
cool that he knows I'm a big guy right
so I gotta do it hey dude this is my
[ __ ] thing it's like
I'm a big guy I gotta do it I'm one of
the taller dudes here I mean most of the
guys were Jewish so I get to the [ __ ]
I get to the thing and I go remember use
your left hand and what do I do dude I
take my right hand and pull it up and
the [ __ ] dad's up and I'm using my
right hand dude hey buddy
cop hey body do what the brain is that
dude I swear to God it was like it was
like when I go to the Dodger games and
I'm like well I'm not gonna eat a Dodger
Dog and I walk in and go directly to the
Dodger Dogs dude well I gotta eat
healthy I don't wanna oh it's like I
didn't like why am I wasting my brain
and body's time
and so I picked the thing up and now I
look and I'm with Joe McIntyre and some
other [ __ ] you know guys that you'd
recognize because this is [ __ ] Adam
knows everybody and I'm holding the
[ __ ] thing and I go oh and I look and
I'm the only one holding the back again
the dad's like two bucks up there
and I'm do and I'm oh God and I [ __ ]
I'm like well I'll be sore tomorrow and
dude it's three days later oh [ __ ] man
anyway dude it was really a [ __ ]
great wedding despite all that mess with
my shoulder
um and then we had some fun times you
know there were a lot of cool people
there you know Eric Griffin was there
Jonathan Kite uh uh and uh you know
Jeremiah Watkins was there
um
and all the girlfriends which was very
sweet Adam DeVine was there super fun
hadn't seen him seen him in a long time
almost dropping my mouth um but yeah man
it was great
that whole wedding was just [ __ ]
um
um yeah
and then we went back to the room dude
and it was and Kristen was already
asleep she went to sleep with uh
he said uh
that that we were going to uh the uh
what was I saying [ __ ] what was I got
them saying I just got a text from Eric
Griffin God damn it uh that's so weird I
was just talking about him
um
yeah no I was saying about how uh they
we went back to the room and Kristen was
already in she was at her aunt's house
sleeping already because you know we had
to relieve the babysitter oh Calvin had
his first thing with the babysitter that
he didn't know and it was [ __ ] it
went gangbusters because it was awesome
her name was Rosa and she was so sweet
and and we didn't even know her yet but
we knew her through the family through
another family and it was just so
awesome Calvin was just chilling and he
and he went to bed and he woke up and
and and she was there and it was great
for nap time anyway that you guys don't
give a [ __ ] about that or maybe you do I
don't know that's my little family
[ __ ] sauce there but
um
crazy crazy
well guys we're going to take a break
here and talk to you I want to talk to
you a little bit about a little bit
something we call diet smoke all right
and here's the deal if you love THC then
you're gonna love diet smoke it's a very
cool name actually I like that all of
diet smokes products are guaranteed to
give you that beautiful Buzz you've been
looking for you've been looking for it
go to diet smoke no prescription
required no awkward conversations no
sketchy weed deals in the back alley or
someone's front porch that you don't
know you don't even need to go to a
store you just decide you want THC and
then they ship THC right to your porch
and your door
this here is pure CBD right there
crazy huh
all of diet Smoke's products are made
from American grown hemp meaning they're
all federally legal uh and each product
has a lab test result for potency and
safety uh they res diet smoke just
released several new flavors and
strengths like blackberry and apple
cider that you've got to try uh I've
never heard of Edibles that have tasted
this good I don't uh I don't know anyone
who doesn't like blackery I don't know
anyone who doesn't like apple cider so
you do the math
um they guarantee 1000 100 satisfaction
one thousand percent satisfaction or
your money's refunded you literally
can't miss with diet smoke so if you're
ready for that perfect high head over to
dietsmoke.com and use code congrats
that's for our listeners and you get 20
off your entire order must be 21 and
older to order back to the show
[Music]
this is the greatest video I've seen of
all time this is so funny and sad at the
same time but God damn this is how is
this a real way to say that he really
did this the thing about the red hat
that drove me to a point of exhaustion
which was misdiagnosed by a I'm not
gonna say what race what people uh
doctor
and what hospital and what media went to
we know I can't say that
it was a Jewish doctor
couldn't help himself
digging so deep guys in China dude can't
like how did he do it honestly take away
the fact that it's anti-semitic I get it
he shouldn't be doing this the guy's
unhinged he's got mental problems you
know it's sadder than it is evil it's
not evil I don't believe he's a bad guy
but I feel like he's got to stop no
one's stopping him we got to stop giving
him Outlets stop recording them dude
let's I don't know it's like it's just
it's not a good idea the guy's unhinged
and he's mentally unstable but my main
quest take away all that how did he do
it
so funny
he did like if this was in a movie I'd
go oh guys should be best actor along
with Javier Bardem in lilac crocodile
and Austin Butler in the Elvis movie
dude
the guy did it the timing of it if you
got it down to the millisecond the
millisecond a fraction of a millisecond
this guy just I mean do you understand
this is funnier than anything Ed Helms
ever did
the thing about the red hat that drove
me to a point of exhaustion which was
misdiagnosed bumbling pie hey I'm not
gonna say what race what people uh
doctor
and what hospital
we know I can't say that
it was a Jewish style
dude he just nailed it this [ __ ] makes
me think that maybe he's actually I mean
I know he's not trolling because you can
see behind his eyes he's got some real
[ __ ] issues but my god dude
he's so funny
and it's sad take away all that you got
to take away all that because if you
actually live in the world and
understand what's happening it's sad if
you think about all that he [ __ ] iced
that [ __ ] comedically
it was a Jewish doctor I mean just like
we knew already you know
well I already know where it was going
and that from jump
so uh Connie is [ __ ] hilarious dude I
feel real you know he's funny like
Trump's funny he's funny you know what I
mean it's
just iced it yes got me got me good oh
it just got me just iced it
um
honestly uh Kanye should just be like
that was my Halloween costume it's just
an anti-semite Adidas let me have that
deal back
I'm a guy tried to go into Skechers
tried to go into [ __ ] Skechers and
then Foot Locker or some [ __ ] and they
were just like now we're good dude I'm
getting turned down by Skechers by the
way Skechers pull some heat I'm not
joking you see some guy dude Uncle Carl
and Tempe had some Sketchers on and I
was like that's kind of heat dude he
doesn't even know it right old men
dictate the track the the trends
straight up
you see what [ __ ] like I mean Uncle
Carl's like 73.
I can't remember really but
um you see a 73 year old wear some [ __ ]
and then like little Dirk or some [ __ ]
it's pretty much the same thing
that dictate he besides all the Iced Out
chains and [ __ ] unless of course the old
man is Italian then forget it but um
yeah man uh
uh Kanye's I don't know
I feel bad about everything but I will
say uh the costumes were
I don't know man these stars who dress
up and get like all the [ __ ] done like
Kim Kardashian did the uh Mystique from
the X-Men and then um
uh uh Diddy did the Joker which is I
mean Diddy is like what is he 50
something and Diddy is like basically
eight I like how Halloween takes people
and turns them into eight-year-olds or
90 right like it's like people who
either like Diddy was just having a
[ __ ] blast
and the costume was so good
I didn't even know it was Diddy and then
uh but to me it's like one night I don't
want to put all that [ __ ] on me man
the what like I did the the um
what do you call the episode of the last
podcast that's we're rebranding and I
was a vampire and Kristen wanted me to
put eyeliner on and the blood coming
down my my my mouth and I didn't want to
do it and I the whole day I felt gross
and I had it on
but now I realize I kind of look [ __ ]
dope in eyeliner and I'm probably gonna
black out my nails too because I'm going
to be [ __ ] sick dude forget it for
real
I'm gonna be [ __ ] sick dude I'm gonna
be like I'm gonna be like one of those
[ __ ] what what is the uh Coheed and
Cambria just [ __ ]
my Silhouette
is uh is a shadow of its former self
just [ __ ] killing it with my black
[ __ ] dude
it was a Jewish doctor
um
Elon Musk
did a
go okay you got Twitter going on and
he's okay he's he's got a committee of
people that
look what he did brought a sink we get
it
weirdest video
like whoever took that video he put the
sink down and [ __ ] fired him as soon
as they stopped recording he goes oh you
fly right because I don't want you to be
having all the [ __ ] in here
I don't know what South African how
about how Trump was like
yeah I should be back on Twitter too
soon congratulations to Elon Musk it's
nice to finally it's nice to be able to
support
um African-American owned business
because of how I mean just trolling
how many times does Trump say live
towards on this on his own you know
dude libtards I heard somebody say it
the other day it's hilarious when people
use that with no like uh what do you
call it uh irony
libtards
[ __ ]
Boomer
I gotta get colonoscopy that's what I
gotta get
I gotta get a colonoscopy because I'm 42
dude I'm gonna be 43 in March and they
say to get it at 45 but they used to say
get it at 40 right they used to get a 40
and now they change it when I turn 40
they say 45 and then I'm like wait a
second didn't my grandma have colon
cancer and I'm like yeah and then I say
well when should I get checked if I have
a family history of colon cancer and
then I'm like I look it up and it's like
if you have a family history of somebody
who had colon cancer you can still get
checked out 45 unless they had it before
they were 55
I'm like when did Grandma have it and
then when should I get checked if she
had it before 55 and then they'd say
well then you should probably get it
checked a little earlier and I'm 42
already so uh oh so then I'm like hey
Mom when did Grandma Carmella yes I'm
Italian
her first bout
of colon cancer and my mama hit me back
and texting me 54.
she
did a stick of metal robber right up my
what the [ __ ] dude give me that good
drink for a day before make me shoot my
brains out put me under for 20 minutes
and stick a metal rod up my ah
whoops meant that one
so it's like I gotta get a colonoscopy
dude I'll take you know what I'll Vlog
it man
hey guys what's up it's Chris Dalia
we're getting a um
we're getting a [ __ ]
because like And subscribe
oh man feels weird
feels weird
oh man know what it feels like I gotta
[ __ ] myself dude that drink I heard was
terrible my buddy said he was drinking
the drink all day and he was [ __ ]
and then he flew to Texas to try and get
a colonoscopy and his buddy was gonna
hook him up his buddy was like a
proctologist whoever does the
colonoscopy and he was like oh oh
um why fly in Friday morning so can I
just come straight there and we do the
colonoscopy and it was like yeah he's
like let's be there is at 11. and so he
was drinking the drink all day at on
Thursday and [ __ ] himself all day on
Thursday and they got on the flight I
guess what dude he had to [ __ ] himself
all the way to Texas man hey guy no
better hey guy you're gonna be leak in
the Nile 14.
you still gotta drink that [ __ ] take
it home drink right not to take it home
but to take it home yeah I know you got
to take the drink home but I'm talking
about hey guys let's take it home that's
the take it home drink before in the
morning you're gonna flush out
completely and then go for your color
not gonna be Duty we [ __ ] in the whole
plane ride that's hilarious man
oh God colonoscopies huh
uh this Facebook thing is crazy stock is
just down hey who would have thought the
people didn't want to be in the
metaverse I wouldn't know actually I
wouldn't know because [ __ ]
dorks can always surprise you
you know what I'm talking about magic
the Gathering oh really swear that much
the Power Rangers Empire ah it's worth
Saban is worth how much
I don't know dorks will trick you you'd
be like who watches that and then oh
dorks come through like the [ __ ]
first scene in Troy
actually it makes me laugh but don't
walk into our world and move out when
walking to the Earth
do you know what I'm talking about
just makes me laugh at people doing but
dork said meta uh-uh metaverse uh
doors go like this we'd rather be losers
in real life than winners and fake ones
gotta hand it to them dorks dude my
buddy's trying to get me to get real
estate in the metaverse and I keep
trying to blow them off like okay maybe
hey let me come over let's talk about
the metaverse I don't want a condo in
the metaverse
I don't even have coins
who would have thunk that nfts the
they've people who have been purchasing
nfts it was a hot commodity for a while
and it went down sales of nfts went down
97
97 people are not buying nfts that's
[ __ ] rappers and Justin Bieber
they're just like okay we did it now
what
nfts
that that's the nft stands for no
[ __ ] that I'm not buying it that's
what it stands for dude
no more
not for this guy that's what nft stands
for now not for this guy anymore
mad humor but you know dude
it's the whole thing about putting on a
[ __ ] helmet you don't want to have to
put on a helmet that's where the
metaverse is [ __ ] you don't want to have
to put up if I could hook in blue
toothically with just my body okay if I
could just go like this
and then hook in with the Bluetooth and
then all of a sudden I see condos that
I'm in that I purchase with Bitcoin or
[ __ ] ethereum whatever the [ __ ]
then okay but if I gotta put on a helmet
and just sit on a [ __ ] couch eating
Funyuns when I know that there's
actually people outside maybe living a
better life but I got a helmet on
dealing with rashes and [ __ ] dude I
gotta you got it the metaverse ain't
ready they're not ready
until
I can hook in with my Bluetooth on my
human body without having to digit I'm
not talking about give me the aux cord
I'll do it through my anus I'm talking
about straight up hooking in Bluetooth
quickly
then fine I'll be royal as [ __ ] I'll
start my own metaverse I'm the only one
in there Royal with just some [ __ ]
you know Bots
bleep it out
just straight give me a royal OTP HJ
you know what I mean oh hey dude hey
where's Chris just sit like this just
like this at Peet's Coffee where's Chris
oh he's getting a royal otphj where's
Chris oh he's just hooked in but he's
not even the aux cord isn't he he's got
no wire tail
what's that mean that's what we use as
[ __ ] aux cord in the anus oh what's
going on he's hooking in through
Bluetooth dude what's he doing he's at
his condo in [ __ ] Narnia just hooked
in getting Royal out to phjs dude
we got the [ __ ] meta Kim Kardashian
just rub an incredulum tip or whatever
the [ __ ]
calling just
we got the meta we got the meta [ __ ]
Kim Kardashian just working his frenulum
tip dude
over some denim
hell yeah dude this is why you listen to
this but who would have thought putting
on a helmet and walking around trying to
find out who else is in the metaverse
made meta AKA Facebook stock went down
dude come to me meta when I can hook in
Bluetooth and get Royal OTP H Shades in
my Miami condo
with the meta Kim Kardashian working my
frenulum gland
but you know I'm right though right but
you know I'm right but yeah he shouldn't
talk about stuff that's so dirty but
it's not dirty because we're in the
metaverse it's not even really happening
dude
I'm clean as [ __ ] and this is what I'm
talking about NPR should be talking
about this
you want to listen to all your other
podcasts talk about you know oh you know
I listen to this [ __ ] I listen to that
[ __ ] all the other comedy podcasts the
other comedy podcast go to them for
comedy but you want the real [ __ ] you
want the raw [ __ ] you want the real the
[ __ ] where we will be talking about
Facebook stock and all of a sudden be
talking about
sitting Royal
in a Narnia condo condo
getting worked by
getting absolutely handled by the
metaverse
Kim Kardashian
just tooling around with your frenulum
gland
where you at MPR
where you at
because right now in the actual
metaverse that's created
I'm a board ape and nobody gives a [ __ ]
it was a Jewish doctor
if this one is an age-restricted I'll be
shocked dude but whatever dude we speak
real and YouTube can [ __ ] subscribe
to the [ __ ] by the way we still have 596
it's a whole thing
it's a whole thing man
I don't really even really believe in
Shadow band but I know they ain't
pushing Us in the algorithm and I know
why because we talk about what we talk
about and you know but this is I got to
give it to you real dude
I'm the Crowder of Comedy or whatever
the [ __ ] that guy's called they keep I'm
gonna be on Rumble soon do it and I'm
not even a [ __ ] far don't push me
that's the whole thing don't push me
dude I'm not on the right I'm in the
center but I'm just saying dude
don't push me speaking of don't push me
here we go dude
oh I just saw this
help this woman DOA to A's at the end
heal from racial trauma now when I read
this headline I go like this okay
I understand trauma is real I suffer
from PTSD it makes my life a living hell
I am not ever really hit with racism I'm
a white guy mostly except for the past
few years because whites kind of took a
dip
I've been living pretty good now it's
harder to be a white guy than ever who
gives a [ __ ] man
I'm still rolling on my dolo and it's
fine okay but you know especially in
Hollywood it's tougher so I'm not
complaining I don't give a [ __ ] give all
the parts to all people of color I don't
care I want for real there to be a movie
about Buzz Aldrin and a trans woman to
play him that I want that the biopic
just like one small step for wait a
minute how what do we actually say I
want that movie
and one giant well it's a definitely a
giant leap for what we can't say mankind
I don't know anymore Flume Netflix just
the woke is [ __ ] so racial trauma I know
nothing about so let's take a gander I
don't look at this and go oh for [ __ ]
sake I'm not a boomer I look at this and
I say let's do some [ __ ] actually
let's take a comb and
we'll see what's going on we'll come
through this it's a GoFundMe a lot of
GoFundMe out there from these out there
are [ __ ] but let's take a fine until
come look at him do this GoFundMe let's
see what that was all about
I don't deal with racism
hello
my name is DOA
I am now let's do the [ __ ] scale here
the the don't push me scale we start at
zero let's start at zero right [ __ ] and
then as it goes we'll see what the don't
push me scale is okay don't push me to
the right I'm a Centrist if you're
watching on YouTube we've got the don't
push me scale and it's my hand
we're starting at zero if you're
listening I feel like you'll probably
get the gist of what's going to be
happening during this bit
all I'm asking dowa
I get racial trauma I don't I don't get
racial trauma I get you get it and I'm
willing to understand that maybe you
need some [ __ ] bags for what happened
all I'm asking for is walk with me
and don't give me two right Wings where
I'm flying around in a circle getting
dizzy because I'm a Centrist
here's the scale and we start the
GoFundMe paragraph here how
has DOA I am a Nubian afro-indigenous
interdisciplinary artist
zeros here I did too many words okay I
don't even care about how you can be
whatever just too many words
but it's not bad we're at like a one or
a two now
and
decolonial practice based researcher
currently residing on the stolen stolen
lands
of the
okay now this is what it says
X High w m upside down e eight k i w a y
upside down e m
what's a high W where's that W going hey
W get a little bit lower and bigger
[Laughter]
in parentheses must Queen never heard of
it
probably my privilege showing let's pick
it up with the left hand dude
oh dude hold on a second
there's another word I don't know s k
with the underlined regular WX with the
underline w u with an accent over it
the number seven
and then the word mesh in parenthesis
in parentheses swirly what tooth peoples
Colonial known as Vancouver dude hair
foreign
so now we gotta start dude don't push me
but now we got to start back at this is
not one this is we're at ten dude
because this ain't over [ __ ]
look the [ __ ] temperature burst all
right let me just read it
it's a really diff it's real it's really
difficult for me to ask for financial
support however I have exhausted all my
options and need my community's help
through my healing journey I work for a
charitable Arts organization and I am oh
you know what actually
we're going down
because I get it you went up a little
bit but let's take it down dude maybe
the thermometer didn't break
it's really difficult for me to ask for
financial support we feel you do it it's
a hard time so we're getting back down
however I have exhausted all my options
that's sad I'm in we're going back down
dude you get me back to Centrist very
good thank you DOA and need my community
to help through the healing Journey okay
we don't like the word healing journey
together but you know what we'll go up a
little bit but we're still here
uh I work for a charitable Arts
organization very admirable let's take a
dip dude we're getting back to one arm
getting back to zero aren't we uh and I
am initiating this GoFundMe because I'm
currently dealing with the impacts of
racial trauma what is it let's hang
tight right here for a second I
experienced at a work event which took
place on April 7th and 8th in 2022 now
you experienced racial trauma hey
proceed now I got my [ __ ] detective
[ __ ] on I got my hat that that's got the
front bill and the back belt and I'm
here with a magnifying glass because if
you experience trauma on April 7th
what you doing
all good I don't know the issue let's
read on
on the seventh I faced racist and
transphobic remarks from an artistic
director working in one of BC's school
districts on the 8th I witnessed a
culturally appropriated appointments
performance by a local non-black hip-hop
instructor who publicly humiliated me in
the black community after I highlighted
her lack of cultural and historical
context about hip-hop
um where am I here
this had to be addressed as it could be
harmful for the children she educates in
school she admitted that her dance
school does not have a single black
instructor because they lack the 10
years of experience she's looking for my
employer took no action with either the
transphobic educator or the dance
instructor not even an email of
acknowledging was of acknowledgment was
sent to the colleagues in support of the
only black employee
I had a mental breakdown and left the
event early with permission from my
employer
only to later receive a text that the
staff photo was overlooked and was taken
without me wow
I was excluded which further alienated
me wow
additionally after this traumatic event
like we got to bend the whole thing
because this woman thinks we're trans I
don't know if she I don't know just
after this traumatic event celebratory
messages were shared internationally
about how successful the event was
completely dismissing my trauma oh my
God until I brought these insensitive
and her truth and hurtful messages to
their attention
okay there's more I don't want to read
it if you're bored go [ __ ] yourself
racial trauma has tremendously impacted
my mental and physical health in ways I
never experienced before
that sentence alone can live
you know I haven't been eating drinking
or sleeping well all right well
that's my sense of taste and smell
change oh
even food I used to enjoy smells
proposal what have you found out later
she's pregnant
I have severe neck and shoulder pain
that I'm currently treating out of
pocket since my extended health coverage
to work has been exceeded
you have shoulder pain because of
a white guy doing hip-hop
I have suffered multiple anxiety attacks
in public which is why I limited
commuting on public transit and I'm
using Lyft Uber instead my ADHD symptoms
worsened as my brain feels extremely
overwhelmed trying to navigate ways to
cope with the trauma financial burden
and stress most of the time I have
extreme fear of leaving my apartment
unless I am with my friends it takes me
hours to play leaving I'm right with you
there but that's because of my OCD and a
lot of times I get so physically
exhausted from thinking and planning I
just give up and don't leave kwell
I recently completed my second ma degree
that resulted in me drowning in more
debt and student loans I intend on push
publishing my ma thesis apply for art
grants
complete our projects and more but
following this trauma I missed every
deadline
is there more
no
hmm
I expected to
expect it to is this a parody
it's real
thank you so much for everyone who
donated here and for e-transferred me
some funds I haven't posted an update in
a bit because I was waiting to hear back
some details from my employer also due
to my severe PTSD resulting from the
racial trauma I have physical symptoms
now every time I think of my workplace
gag nausea severe muscle pain one of the
triggers is my GoFundMe which is why it
took me some time to write an update
here uh
God see
what the [ __ ]
it's like this is the thing man
it's hard enough to deal with somebody
who has one problem this person has 10
problems and it is
expecting the world to bend to it we
can't do that because there's seven
billion people in the world dude if
there were 10 people this woman was in a
class and everyone was like we don't
know what to do with her just leave
there's seven people billion people in
this world if the world changes for you
it's [ __ ] for so many other people
dude put one step in front of the other
and I hate being like this but you push
I'm a Centrist
but you got to just get out there man I
know you're not asking for my advice but
you put it online dude she's got three
thousand dollars she made three thousand
dollars on her GoFundMe who's [ __ ]
donating I'm gonna donate for real
ah what what are you what can you
what can you say to these people it's a
mental condition huh I mean we all have
mental conditions I have mental
conditions I have OCD it's hard for me
do something to trigger my OCD some
things trigger my PTSD
I don't blame anybody about it you know
I try not to I at least try not to right
to get to the point where you're writing
a whole I wish people took
like none of this none of this is her
fault you know and I don't think you
should bully her or this is a comedy
podcast and I feel for this woman man I
just think that she you know people like
this might need some help
I don't feel for her because she got
racially traumatized I feel for her
because this [ __ ] she can't sit in a
class without finding a problem with it
like that she can't even be at home
without finding a problem this is a real
issue dude sometimes my OCD gets the
best of me and I stay in my [ __ ] bed
for a long time
I don't even think about blaming someone
else for that I mean yeah I blame other
people for lots of things like [ __ ]
you know
if I forget to bring water up to the
bedroom when I'm going to bed maybe it's
because my wife distracted me and that's
her fault
but I'm not starting to GoFundMe because
of it guys my wife distracted me when I
tried to go upstairs I needed water I'm
dealing with severe trauma in bed
because I don't want to go downstairs I
can't leave because she knows I have bad
OCD and I already set up for bed so I'm
up here and she wants me to go get water
for her but I was having the water and
then I put it down at the bottom of the
stairs because she asked me to clean the
dishes and you know the dishes were mine
but I cleaned them up and then when I
went upstairs I forgot to water I had
the water anyway I'm trying to get five
thousand dollars because I think that
that's what it's worth that I forgot the
water I woke up parched and my OCD was
absolutely flaming
my wife didn't go get it it resulted in
a [ __ ] uh you know a speed bump in my
marriage so it's like what the [ __ ] do I
do can people donate I probably could
get some money for that honestly I
definitely could get some money for that
if I was indigenous
I'm from the Sioux Tribe secretly
I think my adopted grandmother is Jewish
no no [ __ ] man
[Music]
the doctor was Jewish
um
I think I don't know people think [ __ ]
is crazy but also
there's so many [ __ ] things that are
so crazy out there in the world I just
can't believe it the internet [ __ ]
everything up didn't it because now
these crazy people find each other right
these crazy people find each other she
gets sympathy sympathy and sympathizers
whereas what she needs are doctors now I
don't know this this woman she could be
trolling I have no [ __ ] idea but
people who do this the people that you
don't invite to Thanksgiving now have a
community online on these gofundme's or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
you know and it's like yeah this is it
dude I was watching this thing on Vice
the other day about
uh the targeted community
they think that they're being targeted
for something people think they're being
stalked when they're not being stalked
people think that they're being
um
like literally controlled by electronic
pulses that the government like these
are people that think they're targeted
and know they're targeted even though
they're not and they found each other
online and they identify as a targeted
community
and they're like so happy they found
each other because nobody else gets it
but they're being stalked not stalked
and also
controlled with electronic pulses
through the government not being
controlled by electronic pulses to the
government but they all found each other
and they're all like [ __ ] yeah now we're
thriving and it's like oh but instead of
finding each other
find Alexa Pro
instead of finding each other
snort Alprazolam not that I don't know
I'm not a doctor but it's like dude
and I'm here taking [ __ ] five ants
and I'm here [ __ ] taking an
Alprazolam every time somebody you know
my [ __ ] spikes
I weaned off it all and I never really
had a problem maybe I did I have no idea
what a problem is but my point is
wow my point is wow
um
yeah
it's a weird [ __ ] time man
you talk to 70 year olds about this time
and they're just like oh yeah it's never
been worse
I don't know if that's true right I mean
there is a war in the Ukraine but we're
not there you know maybe it was bad in
Vietnam the time when everybody but
everyone was [ __ ] around then
everyone was like just straight up
squirting
right that was like the free love
movement it was probably really bad in
the 1800s you know people would die
because they got a toothache
times are good let's just realize it how
about that that's the main thing times
are good let's just realize it yeah you
got a white guy coaching hip hop and no
black people in the hip-hop class but
you know what is out the window scurvy
we're gonna be fine you can find a peach
at a [ __ ] Whole Foods near you how
about that
you're not gonna die of scurvy
okay yeah it sucks somebody is
culturally appropriating even though I
don't even believe in that because who
knows where anything started right
people are like don't wear dreads if
you're white but then it's like okay
because black people came up with
dreadlocks but then it's like dude I
watch House of dragons and that took
place in like the year 100 and
everyone's got dreadlocks so it's like
when did it start I watch House of
dragons and you forget that that wasn't
how it was until you see a dragon you're
like oh wait this is fiction man that
show let me tell you something Game of
Thrones not into it House of dragons yes
they did it you know why it's about one
[ __ ] family that's why
I already don't know every but I'm so
bad at knowing people's names I'll be
sitting watching a movie with Kristen
and she'll be like oh I think it's Bob
and I'm like who's Bob and she's like
it's the main character [ __ ] and I'm
like oh yeah no no you're right I [ __ ] I
don't think it names you should have
just said the guy with the wavy hair
so now Game of Thrones comes on I don't
know who anybody is dude you watch the
house of dragons I don't know who anyone
is but also at least I recognize them
because there's not 300 cast members and
of course they had to [ __ ] change the
cast members halfway through because
they made them older fine that's okay I
can deal with it but that shows the [ __ ]
dude why wasn't Game of Thrones more
like House of dragons you know what in
the comments I want to know for real
make a comment if you like House of
dragons more than Game of Thrones
because everyone loves Game of Thrones I
like House of dragons better I don't
mean to go against the grand yeah Mr go
against the grain and I don't mean to go
once against grain
but it's like
House of dragons is this [ __ ] the CGI is
not as good the dragons sometimes look
fake I you know they probably didn't
have the money got has but uh hod has
[ __ ] next year if it's gonna if it's
popping which it is and I like that
[ __ ] Damon guy I think he's a bad guy
because he's like doing a lot of
incestuous stuff but then I realize
everyone's doing incestuous stuff back
then in that time during that time
during that real time period
um but uh I like that show because it's
it's uh
I don't know I like the [ __ ] show
okay what do you want from me I don't
like the movie Barbarian and I really
like Game of Thrones
um
anyway I guess that's it dude we're
having a great time here go to we gotta
we got the um Brea on New Year's Eve
we're gonna be doing that so join me
there should be a lot of fun uh should
be a lot of fun
um in Irvine I'm doing but that's sold
out let's go to uh Denver we'll be in
Denver soon
get your tickets it's almost uh it's
almost uh we got it we sold like 4 000
tickets so far so join us dude funny
[ __ ] Denver and then Cheyenne Wyoming
Seattle's almost done there I'm doing
that January uh January something but
Lakeland Florida I'm going to be there
December like I don't know there's like
a month left why can't I get open these
um Lakeland Florida Boston Massachusetts
November 12th at the Wang theater The
Late Show still has tickets left uh
Lakeland Florida Jacksonville Florida uh
San Diego we added another show Balboa
theater first one sold out Portland
Oregon getting up there Arlene Schnitzer
Concert Hall we love it Seattle
Washington McCall Hall said that
Sugarland Texas New Orleans uh New York
Providence Rhode Island New York I'll be
there February 18th Beacon Theater added
a second show Chicago Illinois February
25th Springfield Missouri and Midland
Texas in March and then where shh Austin
and also Kansas
and also uh we're doing something
the [ __ ]
uh Ohio
got a bunch of say there's a bunch of
big cities in Ohio for some [ __ ] Rich
we're gonna go there
I know the only one I know I'm going to
Cincinnati
but it's coming out dude if you want to
take it we're probably going to do
Cleveland dude
we're probably going to do I hope we're
doing Columbus I don't know
there's so many there's Acorn and Toledo
I don't know if we're doing those but
Ohio is short is small enough that don't
be all like you're not coming to
Cleveland I live about an hour it's a
new Toledo drive to Cleveland
so I'll be there don't tell anyone but
be ready when the [ __ ] drops and then
Austin we're gonna play Moody Blues
that's so many tickets but it's probably
not enough because my family is not
Austin is huge
so make sure when I post without Austin
you're on that [ __ ] and you get it with
the pre with the pre-circle
I'm sure it'll be don't push me oh
lowercase
anyway dude you guys don't tell anyone
hey guys that's it for YouTube if you
want to watch the raw the uncut the
unedited episode of this latest episode
going over to patreon.com crystalia for
all these six months a month bucks a
month for only six bucks for only six
bucks a month you can get that and you
can also get a an extra episode each
month
of congratulations there's like 17 or 18
now so get it now for only six dollars
and you can watch all of those if you're
going on a road trip it also makes a
great holiday present
dad for your loved ones you could be a
producer of the show and get your name
in the credits patreon.com crystallia
and there's also in other segments we do
I got a podcast on Christmas I'm trying
to convince her to come back on and do a
patreon episode she'll be on soon but we
appreciate you and we love you guys
thanks a lot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]